every day we are spending more and more
time inside because of the covert 19
pandemic most of us are self isolating
and working from home which gives us
that little bit more free time to create
something special what's going on guys
my name is Dave atomic should welcome
back to the channel today we're talking
about tick-tock and how you can grow
your account during this period
self-isolation if you're new to the
platform if you've been on for a while
or if you have absolutely no idea what
tick tock is this is the perfect video
for you okay so let's start with the
absolute basics what is tick tock tick
tock is basically Instagram Facebook
Twitter YouTube all meshed into one
crazy platform for all sorts of
different creative ideas and vertical
videos basically what you need is a
15-second vertical video up to 60
seconds in the length and all you have
to do is post it most of the time people
getting very creative with their edits
with their techniques and other things
like that so potentially you might need
a video editing app in conjunction with
tick-tock or you can also film it
directly in the app itself from the very
first day when you start creating an
account selecting your profile picture
and running your bio is where the magic
happens and if you want to be tick-tock
famous this is where you got to spend a
little bit of time creating a unique
profile picture with a nice bright
background behind you very professional
very clean-looking gives you a much
higher chance that people following you
along the way whereas if you just have a
raggedy old photo that you've found I
don't know 400 photos deep into your
camera roll six years ago well that's
definitely the wrong photo to use your
username is again very very important
when you start ticked off account you
want to make sure it's clear concise and
memorable if it's memorable you know
people are going to be able to search
for you very quickly and lastly for the
basics tik-tok works very similar to
Instagram it searches through
of hashtags that are trending and
popular and getting some traction to
really promote your videos so the more
your hashtags are relevant trendy
appropriate to your channel and videos
the more your videos they're going to
get seen so from a basics point of view
all tick-tock is is a very easy to set
up of profile pictures and buyers 15 to
60 second vertical videos of absolutely
anything you can think of and a fun
place to spend some time so now that
we've got the basics out of the way
we're really gonna start talking about
how to grow it tick tock in isolation if
you're looking to grow you have to be on
the platform you have to know what's
going on what's trending what's not
because unlike YouTube and Instagram
trends change so quickly on tick tock in
24 hours it's a different challenge a
different trend and something different
going viral so if you aren't on it
consistently then you have no idea and
you're out of the loop what was cool and
trendy a week ago is basically all news
now and you can just forget about it and
do more about posting it the good thing
is you don't need an account on tik-tok
to actually start viewing the content
and understand what you should start
posting because you first find videos on
tick tock a creeper the first 5 videos
that you post on tick tock will allow
the algorithm to determine what kind of
niche your channel is and what kind of
content you're actually producing is it
high quality low quality is a be paying
attention is a good promote so these
first 5 videos you want to make sure
that they are the best of the best that
you can absolutely create after that
obviously you want to create very
similar very strong content but it isn't
going to be as imperative that these
videos are as good what you notice is
tick-tocking doesn't have the highest
quality videos and that's because people
are pumping your content like crazy
content is key on tick tock we're
talking three to five videos a day at
absolute minimum now that's almost a
full-time job for most people to produce
three to five pieces of
every single day but if you want to
become tick-tock famous in isolation you
have to pop out good content
consistently good content doesn't just
mean creative content it also means high
quality videos and high quality lighting
so if you're filming in a dark room by
yourself very quiet the really
struggling talking wack phone well then
it's not gonna go well you are gonna
have to step out into the light even if
it's next to a window to get some good
lighting and really improve the quality
of your videos if you have an iPad and
then you have a brand new iPhone make
sure you use the iPhone to film these
and not be iPad anything that has a
better quality camera use that as a
preference first once you publish these
first five videos potentially in the
first day you want to follow it strong
with consistent content you want to
continue making the same style of
content that you've been doing in that
first day so if you selected a niche
like technology for example what we
talked about here in this YouTube
channel then you continue with
technology related videos give it a
couple weeks of a very strong consistent
performance to see if you can hit that
hundred K mark it is relatively easy to
jump on tik-tok do a bunch of trendy
videos consistently over and over and
over and over again for a week and go
from zero to a hundred thousand
followers so again if this is something
you're looking for you know have to
commit and really push through the first
week to get it's important to note that
three to five videos daily is good but
once your video is start really shining
through in games and views you want to
put in some fillers in between two so
for example if one of your video gets
300,000 views out of nowhere and you've
been consistently getting 30,000 then
you quickly want to chuck in a couple
videos extra that day if something is
getting that higher-end views then you
want to throw an additional two videos
per day so we're talking up to seven
times per day on tick tock now that is
a lot of content especially if you don't
live in America or if you don't live in
Australia that you have to post at
ridiculous times to try and get the
masses on tik-tok it means staying up
late working really hard and producing
automotive content potentially even
prior to starting your account to make
sure you have that availability and have
that flexibility to continue posting
when the time comes now here's where it
gets a little bit weird and a little bit
tricky
tick tock doesn't like you deleting your
content from the algorithm point of view
you shouldn't actually be deleting
anything if you have less than 1% views
versus your followers after 2 weeks of
that video being up then you can
actually delete it and tick tock won't
see as a huge negative and rank your
account lower what I mean by this is if
you have a hundred followers and your
video only gets one view half two weeks
then definitely delete that video
because it'll bring down your rankings
however if after one week or two weeks
it's always had one view and then a
couple days later it spikes really
quickly don't delete it
tick tock has this unique algorithm that
promotes videos and gives them a second
chance so unlike Facebook where most of
our content goes up for 24 hours and
disappears regardless of how good that
content was tick tock will again push
that to its audience and the people on
the platform a few weeks a few days
later depending on the content so even
though you've had one view for 8 days by
that day 9 and 10 it could have a
hundred thousand views along with all
that information I've just told you
there is three C's to remember copy
create and collaborate you want to be
copying as many viral trends as you can
as quickly as you can the more viral
trends you get on the more views you can
get seen for example the duet feature
and tick tock allows you to basically
piggyback on somebody else's success so
somebody has 20
views and you do a duet there video
there's a very high probability that
your video is going to get a lot more
likes than your just publishing in your
random content you also want to be
creating unique stuff every now and
again nobody just wants to see you doing
the same trend 17 other people did
before you in the same video everybody
wants to see new creative content that's
what the industry is built on that's
what Instagram for I've done while
Facebook there I've done that's how
YouTube became such a huge hit we went
from laughing at cats and dogs on
YouTube to watching vloggers talk about
their lives and recording every minute
of their day so you really want to try
and be one of these first people in the
early adopters of tick tock to push
unique content when you have such a
unique opportunity and lastly just like
YouTube you want to collaborate with
your friends collaborate with anybody
you know collaborate and do a copying of
a viral trend collaborate and do a
unique piece of content it doesn't
matter
the more people you bring on the more
you link up with the more your face is
seen on other videos the better it is
for you now if you're stuck here
thinking I don't know what kind of niche
to start I don't know tik-tok to start
what am I gonna do my life's pretty
boring well let's think of something
that you can do together this is a tech
channel for example so I could easily go
and start a tip top account and review
tech product in 15 seconds why not 15
seconds very short bursts
this product has this this this picture
these are the goods they for that would
I buy it no yes done it is quick enough
to retain people's attention and it is
engaging enough to hold them there for
the full 15 seconds and get really high
quality views if you have the travel bug
and love traveling you maybe have a
video real of millions and millions of
videos backlogged already how about to
start a highlight reel 15 seconds of the
most beautiful places you've ever been
to in the highest quality you can
produce but what if you want to go
completely left-field t-top right now is
you need platform live nobody knows how
to monetize properly nobody knows how to
turn it into a venture or a business
what happens if all of a sudden you
become the media you become the news of
five you become the Fox News or CNN
whatever it is in your hometown so one
of my final thoughts on tick-tock well I
think personally the tick-tock is a fun
entertaining app that really just passed
some time for the time being however is
something that will turn into something
much much bigger just like Instagram
started of people taking photos of their
food and now is one of the biggest
social media platforms where people make
a livelihood from tik-tok will be the
same it started as little dance videos
and trendy hip videos that are gonna
explode into some sort of creative media
complex I think the people the famous on
tick-tock right now are gonna disappear
very very quickly
everybody that's become famous on
tick-tock has become famous from trends
nobody has developed their own unique
niche I guess it's a continuation of
what everybody else has done it's very
similar to YouTube and Instagram how
people who jumped on the bandwagon of
vlogging and travel photography and all
that once it was too late I think
tick-tock is going to explode even
further than it has so if you are able
to create that unique niche and be very
different it might take you a lot longer
to peak but you will pick very quickly
if you're serious about tick-tock make
sure you look for it is not going to be
easy posting three to seven pages of
content every single day is hard work
there is no doubt about that and don't
take that away from anybody to succeed
your own tick-tock anyway that's all for
me guys
today thank you so much for watching I
hope you enjoy this unique piece of
Quarantine content if you did smash that
subscribe button
20:20 style and I'll see you in just a
couple of days